>>When we started this process twenty
years ago, what it looked like then
and what the products looked
like then were very different
than they look like now.
>>Narrator: These teachers at King
Middle School in Portland, Maine,
are pioneers of expeditionary
learning, a teaching method
that uses project based learning
and real world experience
to engage students and
encourage collaboration.
>>And now we're fine
tuning more than we were.
Before, we were sort of
going at it with a hatchet
and we were hacking stuff to pieces,
'cause we didn't all understand
what was going on and a lot
of people were resisting the change.
But now, I think it's fine tuning
a product to a certain extent.
>>I do know that after
our first expedition,
the thing that we all sat
back and looked at was,
prior to when you had parents'
open house, you would go
and select the best and
put that on the wall,
and you would hide the
others in the drawer.
And with the-- our first expedition,
every end product was just unreal.
From your gifted student
to your special ed student,
every end product was unreal.
So we bought into it,
and we said okay,
and then developed
the other expeditions.
As long as it was relevant
and we also made sure
that it was curriculum driven,
not just pie in the sky,
but driven by our curriculum.
>>Yeah, and just one
piece that I think is one
of the most challenging things about
expeditionary learning practice is
that when you have seven adults
around a table who are trying
to figure out what they're gonna
make with kids, it's very difficult
to have a really deep, meaningful
conversation around curriculum
and how that's all gonna fit together
if you don't actually have the thing
made and can look at it and say,
"For science, I know how I can
contribute to that, or for math,
I know how I can contribute to that."
And if the thing that you make
doesn't match everybody's needs,
then you can change it so it
does match everybody's needs.
So I'm hoping that our work
around getting exemplars made
in advance will help that whole
dialog around how to connect the kind
of learning that's most important.
Instead of just making
the thing we can make,
we're making the thing we can make
because it makes the
most sense for learning.
>>And the debrief piece is a huge
thing at the end of an expedition.
The kids give us feedback
and they're the real--
in my opinion, they're the real
places where we want feedback,
because they point out
things that we may not get,
or it may not be a direct feedback.
It may be you notice that
none of them get one idea,
or that all of them-- only 30 percent
of them completed this aspect of it,
or this assignment,
getting ready for it.
And a lot of times, that's where
you can really see how they struggle
with certain aspects of it.
>>To me, what's challenging in an
expedition is the schedule, is like,
it's just so hard to predict
where the kids are gonna be.
And you know, sometimes if they
wanna go off on this, you know,
kinda dig a little deeper, it kinda
throws everything off and it just--
so having that deadline
is tricky for me.
>>Yeah, I think deadlines,
'cause like we had a snow day.
[laughter]
>>We had the flu.
>>And it killed us.
I mean, that was a work day.
We had one expedition where
it was a culminating event,
was a dinner for about 150 people
on a Friday and we had a snow day.
>>Twice, right?
>>Yeah, twice.
And we're panicking.
And just to find the space or what
to do with it, but it all works.
>>So it all comes down to the
way we approach it as teachers
and how we organize for kids'
learning, using the laptops.
So we've been asking people to look
at putting these learning materials
and organizing these learning
materials in an index, online,
so that when we ask kids to go
and do this kind of research,
they're not off in left field.
And when we tell them
that they're accountable
for finding good information, we
know that information's out there,
because we're already
organized it and it's there,
so we hold them accountable
in the same way we've always
held them accountable.
But we used to do it-- I remember in
the old expeditions, at the beginning
of an expedition, you would
hand out a big journal
of all the reading
assignments, in a binder.
>>We'd go to the library
and get all the books that--
>>Every single thing
would be all there.
And now what we're saying is,
that's still the right way to do it,
except we have a huge world
of options open to us,
and now that means we can
grab so many better pieces.
But again, it ups the
ant in terms of planning.
We have to plan harder and plan
better and we have to make sure
that we have what I call the
developmentally appropriate materials
for all learners.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org